[Musique]
l'excitation et l'effervescence des
grands jours après 5 ans d'absence le
Cirque du Soleil fait son grand retour
devant le public français avec l'une de
ses productions phare curios à
l'approche de la première l'heure est
aux dernières répétitions en ce moment
les acrobates vérifient que que tout est
bien que la tension du filet est bien
donc il vérifi aussi la que les
plateformes soient bien à niveau puis
tout ça pour que les artistes soient
confortables et puissent présenter les
acrobaties de haut niveau pour atteindre
l'excellence des années de préparation
on été nécessaire pour créer ce
spectacle un travail qui depuis la
création de la compagnie québécoise en
1984 ne cesse de
fasciner
avec près de 3000 collaborateurs la
magie s'opère aussi en coulisse où tout
doit être parfait bonjour je suis Becky
Williams bienvenue dans les backstage
ici nous avons certains accessoires donc
nous avons
464 accessoires ici vous voyez beaucoup
de choses inspirées de la révolution
industrielle le train à vapeur et le
grammophone un de mes accessoires
préférés que nous avons sur le spectacle
on vient de recevoir la touche finale
c'est la main mécanique on l'utilise
pendant le numéro de
[Musique]
contorsion
bienvenue dans laattente des artistes
ici les artistes viennent s'entraîner se
reposer et même se préparer ils
disposent également de leur propre
dressing bonjour je suis Mar je suis la
chef costumière bienvenue dans l'atelier
des costumes suivez-moi on a beaucoup de
travail en vue de cette grande
première alors vous pouvez voir nous
avons beaucoup de perruques beaucoup de
costumes beaucoup de gens travaill
dessus c'est près de 8000 costumes et
accessoires qui sont entreposés ici
chaque pièce est unique et repousse les
limites de
l'imagination on voyage avec beaucoup de
maquillage avec tout ce dont nous avons
besoin pour réparer les costumes donc
nous avons beaucoup de projets
d'envergure et nous avons beaucoup de
travail pour être prêt pour la
première une machine à rêve qui réunit
une cinquantaine d'artistes de 20 nation
tion différent
oui au sein de curios nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup de nationalités c'est
agréable d'être avec eux et de voir
comment il travail voir leur culture
comment ils font ce qu'ils font c'est
juste une belle façon de vivre un mode
de vie synonyme de fierté pour les
membres de la compagnie il y a tous les
amis toute la famille qui vont venir
bien sûr ils sont déjà venus avant mais
il y en a d'autres qui vont pouvoir avir
la chance de pouvoir venir vu qu'on est
plus proche et ça met une petite
pression bien sûr on est en France donc
on a envie de bien faire on a envie de
bien présenter le show et est super
content ou d'être d'être ici quoi depuis
39 ans la compagnie a conquis près de
375 millions de spectateurs à Chatou
2500 personnes sont attendu dès la
première le Cirque du Soleil enchantera
l'île des Impressionnistes jusqu'au 14
janvier 2023